is about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood on uncensored
tonight from boycotting work companies
to only buying ethical Brands culture
warriors on both sides demand we shot
our values but during cost of living
crisis is it a price that consumers
should be willing to pay
a lawsuit in the US meanwhile is trying
to prove the U.S government pressurized
social media companies to censor dissent
around covid mandates now critics say it
is just another conspiracy we'll be
debating that
and is the number one song on the
Billboard Chart really a racist dog
whistle country music fans are standing
by their map
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood welcome to Piers Morgan
on Center with me Rosanna Lockwood still
here whilst Pierce's way having well
probably not having to fight for some
but if we're being honest but at least
he's having a nice time now go woke or
go broke that's a topic that pierce
talks about a lot it's the phrase of
course associated with companies
exploiting social justice causes in
their branding efforts you know the big
ones recently Bud Light in the US
featured a trans influencer Dylan
Mulvaney and then they saw their own
sales absolutely plummet off the back of
that meanwhile here in Britain people
boycotting Costa Coffee over this
illustration of what appeared to be a
post-op transgender man caused a lot of
debate that did well to me all of this
is Corporate exploitation of everyone
involved to others it's virtue signaling
and they actually design their lives
around avoiding it there's even a new
app that will allow you to shop your
values simply by scanning a barcode
because it really does get people hot
under the collar doesn't it this topic
including the very man whose seat I'm
keeping warm tonight
but there's a problem I hate you
I don't simply care if you know it at
some unidentified point in recent
history companies lost interest they
simply selling things and decided it was
their duty to change the way that you
and I think someone somewhere say
corporate board members of the World
Unite and suddenly the people who sell
you fizzy drinks and credit cards were
also telling you that black lives matter
that pride month is more important than
Christmas you're personally to blame for
climate change because of your filthy
carbon footprint and so on and so on
well at the moment all of this is very
much focused on this woke or anti-woke
issues but it is nothing new remember do
you remember this is the Uproar about
the Nestle Yorkie chocolate bar their
campaign in the early 2000s saying it's
not for girls well as far as I lost yet
your keeper bars still exist women still
dare to eat them may include and we're
still talking about them so that is
exploitative marketing done right so
sometimes the gamble does pay off and
sometimes in the case of Bud Light it
doesn't but what about when money gets
tight for consumers like at the moment
with Sky High inflation do you really
stick to your values when it comes to
your shopping list in the cost of living
crisis what is more important values or
value for money today it was announced
that sales at Beyond meats that make a
vegan Burgers have fallen by almost a
third now this is in part because
consumers are choosing cheaper regular
animal products going back to the
traditional old meat now it's highly
unlikely isn't it the vegans are
suddenly giving up on veganism only
about one to two percent of the UK's
population has actually estimated to be
vegan and yet one report found nearly a
quarter of all food products launched in
2019 were labeled vegan now from a
business perspective that is just absurd
if you ask me too much expensive Supply
not enough core demand means that vegan
food bubble is bursting so is it a
triumph over woke I don't think so I
think it's a Triumph of Market forces
and consumer Choice vegan alternatives
are always still going to be there
they'll just be fewer of them and they
might be cheaper because those companies
are now scrabbling to lower their prices
to keep all of us buying so my question
is this what if cost a coffee suddenly
started offering 50 pence Lattes or if
Bud Light sold 50 Cent beers would those
values-based boycotts continue or would
value for money begin to Triumph there
too in this economy I don't think anyone
any of us should be attacked for buying
whatever we can afford ignore the
culture wars things are hard enough
enjoy the savings where you can make
them joining me to discuss all of this
talk TV presenter Richard Tice and
political journalist Ava Santina thank
you to you both also joined by Chris
Rhodes founder and CEO of veeps this new
shopping app we were just talking about
promises to help Shoppers find brands
that align with their values Chris
thanks for making time for us just start
off very simply by telling us how the
app works
sure yeah the veebs app is designed to
make it effortless to shop based on your
on your values the way it works is you
download the app you get the 99 per
month subscription uh you load up the
value pack that most aligns with what
you you know your interests are um
there's seven to choose from and then
you're ready to shop you go to the store
you scan the product you're thinking
about buying beeps returns a value score
from one to a hundred based on that
company's uh values uh and and the ones
that you chose then you're able to say
that's good or it's not good if it's too
low leads offer some Alternatives it
might fit you better you can look at
those Alternatives choose do I want a or
do I want B pick the one you want put it
in the cart and you move on to the next
thing it makes it easy it makes it you
know you use your normal shopping
routine and most importantly we keep
everything updated so you don't have to
be digging down internet Rebels all day
and you're not targeting any side in
particular audience you're looking at
all lens of spectrum from Liberal to
conservative so in terms of the data
that you've picked up on so far the
users as far as I know it's only based
in the US so far your app
um what are you noting from that do you
find it's more liberals or more
conservatives using it yeah so we
haven't done a ton of marketing yet so
we don't have a marketing campaign to
really count against so it's really been
very new cycle driven so far and we see
spikes in all seven uh different value
packs that we have uh based on kind of
what's happening in the news so far
we've seen you know based over the last
month that we've been on the market it's
obviously been a big month for
conservative news stories we've seen a
lot of conservative uptake and that's
definitely the majority but we see
spikes here and there of of all seven
do you get on board with the argument
I've been making that the companies are
basically just exploiting everyone at
this point in the pursuit of just making
a quick Buck whether it be left or right
everyone involved is just being
exploited
I don't think everybody I don't think
every instance of values uh signaling is
exploited
um but I think there are certainly
companies that are trying to jump on
that bandwagon and gain market share or
or whatever based on uh you know a value
story that that they may or may not be
be wholeheartedly believing in
um so yes there's some of that going on
I do think you know you don't
necessarily have to make a decision
either values or savings um you just
need the right data to make the decision
um and so that's kind of what we we're
trying to offer at veeves is the ability
to go to your regular store your regular
aisle choose a you know product based on
your values we know the pricing will be
more or less similar in the same aisle
and hopefully you can buy on your
conscience but also
um you know save money that's a dream
isn't it give people the choice to make
those informed decisions whether it be
based on value or values let's come to
the panel Chris stay with us we'll come
back to you but you were listening to
that Richard and Ava quite fascinating
isn't it would you use the app I love it
I mean that is the American dream isn't
it it's free market forces working out
their best Christie's identified a space
in the market and he's basically with a
subscription base he's gone in the
middle he says which do you want and
it'll be fascinating to see how it goes
my question to Chris is is when's it
coming to the UK because look I've this
only this week I've stopped buying Costa
Coffee I put a tweet out there yeah I
just think they they've suffered so they
haven't exploited people they've made a
terrible mistake just like Bud Light did
and they're paying the price for it and
you know that's what happens with boards
you make decisions you make mistakes
they'll learn from it so you make your
values based decisions in shopping
you've decided to boycott Costa when it
cut I know you're an investor you're a
businessman as well have you ever
invested in companies that had links to
for example arms manufacturers tobacco
so you've made values based decisions on
that side as well actually In fairness I
don't think I've ever been presented
with an opportunity but I'm a real
estate guy I'm a property guy so no I'm
focused on what I know and look I just
think that lots of companies recently
they've tried to Virtue signal it you
saw it with Coots they've made some
terrible mistakes but equally what you
don't hear about is the Smart Companies
that focus on looking after what
actually the customer wants a good
product at a competitive price
fundamentally that I think is what most
people want at any time of a cycle in
particular when money is really really
tight we will get back to Chris and ask
him whether he fancy said Governor UK
what he hears this conversation
he might be put off Ava coming to you uh
on this I mean exploitative that's what
worries me about the Costa Coffee side
of things when it comes to trans people
and the way they're being represented
the Dylan malvaney case in particular uh
that person that individual she felt
that she was left by the company
abandoned yeah I mean well she was
abandoned because that that campaign
blew up completely out of proportion it
was never meant to be an ad campaign it
was a little bit of sponsored content
that went way out of the you know way
out of the water and it means that
people were like Richard and I were
talking about it on panels in a way that
I don't think Dylan expected and I don't
think Bud Light did either I'd like to
go back a little bit though to your
point about veganism earlier I I think
that the reason that beyond beyond meat
are failing is because the product is
not very good I've been a vegetarian for
nearly 20 years now I mean I don't go
after products because they are
virtually signaling or because they are
you know well packaged I go after them
because they're healthy and a lot of the
Alternatives that have come out in the
past few years aren't so it doesn't
matter if you put a trans flag on there
if it's not healthy I'm not going to eat
it what do you make of all the sort of
politicization of corporate products and
food products in the time of what we're
calling a cost of living crisis where
people are strapped anyway do you think
people feel judged for their decisions
in the supermarket um I think that
people should feel judged but not in the
supermarket I think you can look at you
know companies like shell and BP who
have been greenwashing for the past 10
years so these huge oil companies that
make these big ad campaigns claiming
that they are environmentally friendly
and therefore you should go and fill up
your car there that's where our concerns
should be not a tiny little coffee
company like Costa which I'm sorry that
little sign that showed a double
mastectomy I mean I could care it was
grotesque it was abusive it was
exploited it was the most revolting
thing I can think I've seen in an
advertising why were you celebrating the
mutilation of healthy breasts why were
you so offended Richard I was offended
because I just thought it was awful my
other half Isabelle was a appalled by it
and we just told it as we see it and I
think that I think Costa will deeply
regret that were you offended over not
at all and also there's no indication to
show that that is supposed to be a
depiction of someone who is trans like
what else is it that could just be
someone who has had a double mastectomy
which is quite common I really don't
mind that at all I just don't think that
the coffee there is very good that's why
I don't go there but absolutely but you
know yeah well let's bring that up
because a lot of these High Street
coffee chains at the moment are also
Under Fire for passing on a lot of these
high input costes we call them inflation
onto the customer you go and buy a
coffee and a pastry it's cost you just
shy of 10 quid here in London you know
somewhere around the city
I'm talking about the main ones I won't
name them uh you know if if and and if
they're also pushing values as well do
you think they're essentially going to
lose consumers over I don't know I think
it actually might be a way to get
consumers to go there I mean if you look
at Starbucks for example the main reason
that young teenage girls go there is
because they like the photograph with
their coffee I mean if this is something
that you align yourself with if you're a
big leave from the LGBT you know
community and movement and you want to
be a part of it then great get your
consumers that way Richard just won't go
I won't go there but I go to I go to
press because it's better value that's
what I just you know I'm a subscriber
and I'm looking for value for money
that's what I'm really excited as well
as quality I'd love us to have a
conversation about the sort of
exploitation that goes on abroad okay so
if you look at fast fashion you look at
where we're getting coffee from where
these companies
it would be because actually the
hypocrisy of many people young people
who buy clothes wear it once and then
ditch it because it's so cheap fast
fashion but you know they're exploiting
uh people in developing countries who
are being paid an absolute pittance if
you pull the thread on most things in
this studio what we're wearing
everything we eat and breathe you can
almost always find abuse along the chain
uh I think making people more aware of
it of course and allowing them to make
informed decisions speaking of which
let's go back to Chris who's developed
this app veebs which does allow people
to make these values based choices when
it comes to these kind of culture War
issues Chris he had a chance to listen
to that debate here in the studio that's
a couple of Brits talking about values
and shopping are you enticed to bring it
up over here absolutely uh we've gotten
a ton of uh interest from Great Britain
and Australia in particular a little bit
from the rest of Europe and and we
definitely are looking uh at those as
our first Geographic expansions
um we want to have you know more
products more customers here as we build
a foundation but uh there is a lot of
enthusiasm for this from Great Britain
in particular Chris can I just ask you
what strikes you as
um
comparatively between the U.S sort of
cultural that's going on with regards to
products and shopping and the UK as well
do you think they're similar or do you
think that Britain is different to the
US in any way
um I you know I think they are
relatively uh similar to be honest with
you um in a lot of ways in that there's
kind of two sides there's there's a you
know maybe
um each side
calling hypocrisy on on a number of
things
um I think it's a little bit of a
different starting point
um you know Great Britain and the US
have uh you know a different kind of
cultural foundation and with brexit
that's a kind of a big uh
turning point maybe in in Britain that
we we didn't have as much here that
makes it a little bit different but
there's people who want to shop on their
values there's people who want to um
make their dollar or pound go as far as
it possibly can while buying on their
conscience and you know we want to
address that need Chris Rhodes of veeds
I will look forward to seeing the app
when it lands here in the UK best of
luck and Richard and Ava are going to
stay with us throughout the show thanks
for joining us for that first section
now and uncensored next tonight it's
social media companies conspire with the
Biden Administration to censor cover
descent online a court case in America
is arguing just that we'll have both
sides of that debate after this break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
now it has been described as one of the
most important Free Speech cases in U.S
history now I'm not talking about
Trump's third indictment a class action
against the Biden Administration for
allegedly colluding with and coercing
social media platforms to suppress
disfavored speakers viewpoints and
content during the covid pandemic make
no mistake this is a lawsuit of which
the outcome could have implications for
us or wide-ranging and massive indeed
joining me to debate there's two very
interested parties Dr J bhattacharya is
a co-signatory to this lawsuit a very
outspoken voices against lockdowns
during the Kobe pandemic and former
White House coronavirus response
coordinator Dr Deborah Burks who
publicly witnessed one of the most
infamous it could be called moments
during the pandemic let's just remind
ourselves
right and then I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by injection inside or or almost a
cleaning because you see it gets in the
lungs and it does a tremendous number
along so it'd be interesting to check
that
Dr Deborah I will come to you first on
that I know you probably end up getting
asked this a lot we don't want to dwell
on that past too much uh but I remember
watching that very clearly listening to
the president at the time Donald Trump
talking about that talking about
injecting bleach watching you on the
sidelines there and wondering what was
going through your mind
well you know he was talking to Dr Brian
you could see his head and you can see
he's turned away from me and
um we actually had scientist Dr Bryant
do a study so the kids would get back
outside it was April it was spring I was
worried about kids being inside
um Mayors would not let they closed all
the playgrounds and I wanted children
out on the playground so we asked the
scientists to study sunlight compared to
disinfectant for metal plastic and
cardboard to be able to reassure parents
and mayors that children could go
outside because the sun was a great
disinfectant for covet somehow between
when we discussed that at task force and
45 minutes later when we came to the
Press briefing
I think Dr Brian had gone to the oval
and engaged the president in discussing
this as a therapeutic it was never
studied as a therapeutic it was studied
in fact that would be dangerous it was
studied for playgrounds and to get
children outside so you're saying there
was a bit of a miscommunication uh going
on and I do want to say you've got a
book coming out silent Invasion the
untold story of the Trump Administration
covid-19 and preventing the next
pandemic before it's too late of which
our viewers can maybe hear a bit more
about that but Dr J bhattacharya I want
to come to you on this court case we're
hearing about the moment the Biden
Administration well a case against the
bite Administration this idea that the
government allegedly is coercing or
suppressing social media companies to
silence voices like yours I think it's
fair to say because you have said you've
been sort of Shadow banned on Twitter
for example for things you've said about
lockdowns what made you a co-signatory
on this lawsuit
that there's not there's nothing alleged
about it the Biden Administration has a
uh an enormous censorship complex
basically aimed at controlling and
silencing voices on social media that
criticize its policies in fact it uses
the the the muscle it has over the
regulatory you know regulation of social
media to to induce uh Twitter uh
Facebook you name it to uh to just to
slag lockdown opponents uh and and in
fact to suppress criticism of the
misinformation that the Bible
demonstration itself is putting out on
on things like uh you know immunity
after coveted recovery on the inefficacy
of the vaccine to stop disease spread uh
on on the efficacy of mass vastly
overstating the evidence on that on the
harms of the school closures uh it was
on item after item what you see is the
by Administration suppressing the speech
of of of of critics using its government
power to censor in a way that is not
consistent with the American First
Amendment uh well it's alleged until
it's proven in a court of law of course
and that's what we'll have to wait and
see uh but thanks for setting out your
stall on that Dr Burke I want to come to
you and get your response to that
because you have said previously with
regard to kind of the post-match
analysis even though some would argue
the pandemic's still going that some of
the backlash backlash against the way it
was handled to some extent is deserved
or warranted do you think the same with
this social media argument
well you know I loved your last segment
because it talked about empowering the
consumer with all the information they
needed in order to make decisions on
what to buy and even today we don't put
transparent information out there about
infectious diseases I mean we're talking
about an app on buying coffee and we
don't have an app where everybody across
the world can see what's circulating in
their area so they can make decisions
about themselves and their families
because there are people that are still
very vulnerable to covet my mother is 94
in a multi-generational household yes
she's been vaccinated but you know
vaccines and someone that Elderly with
that poor of an immune response she may
not mount an immune response and so it's
my job to provide the tools that we have
to protect her but every family is
different and that's why I've always
found I've worked in pandemics around
the globe if you empower the community
with the information that they need they
will make Common Sense decisions that
protect themselves and their families
I've seen this with covid I've seen it
with Sika I've seen it with ebola and I
don't know why we can't give people
transparent information that they can
utilize on a day-to-day basis well
certainly plenty of Health officials
yourself included both of you trying to
get the information that you saw was
writing scientific out during the
pandemic also Dr fauci also here in the
United Kingdom Chris Whitty these top
scientists but it could be argued that
the relationship between the public and
the scientists the public health
authorities broke down so dramatically
over the course of the pandemic where
that was due to government Behavior or
what some would call unelected
bureaucrats overstepping the line
depending on what side of the argument
you sit on but in terms of disseminating
that information and the public actually
taking it on board Dr bhattacharya can
you not understand that there is an
element of misinformation when it comes
to things like Twitter or should we
publish call it now X does it not
concern you
I mean I think the the solution to
misinformation of any sort is uh is
trust and what happened during the
pandemic is that the government it's
embraced uh censorship and embraced uh
positions that were contrary to the
science and then closed up the
possibility of debate and criticism from
the outside and as a result vast numbers
of people no longer trust the government
production the information that provides
and so when there is actual
misinformation of foot
um you know there's they're not going to
trust uh you know the uscdc or the US
NIH anymore because the NIH and the CDC
itself embraced in misinformation uh so
if you want to combat misinformation the
answer is not censorship the answer is
is to build trust in public institutions
by behaving in trustworthy ways and that
is not what happened by the way a court
actually did find the findings it's not
no longer alleged the court actually did
find uh that the sense is going on body
by Administration is these are facts
that were entered in court not just
distributed by the government their
emails depositions of Tony fauci and
others in the government who
participated in the censorship
industrial complex uh I just want to ask
you what that trustworthy Behavior would
look like if you boil it down because if
you have that volume of information
coming at the public they're trying to
work out who they can trust or not and
this is what the covert pandemic felt
like for many what does that trustworthy
Behavior look like how can people
discern it
well I think one is humility and
openness to to criticism right so if you
have a a high government official saying
if you criticize me you're not simply
criticizing a man you are criticizing
science itself well that's just
ridiculous no one who can look at that
and say well yeah that person actually
is is able to keep an open mind and see
if he's wrong admit it
um that kind of behavior exemplifies
exactly how the government behaved
throughout the pandemic and as a result
a tremendous number of people and they
got things wrong it wasn't simply that
they were embracing science and they got
it right and they're criticizing people
on the outside who got it wrong they got
things wrong over and over and over
again the app the uh they over emphasize
the efficacy of masking and mass
mandates they are they ignored immunity
after covert recovery
um they they they they ignore the the
the vast evidence that if you get the
vaccine you can be infected again oh and
in Embrace mandates in its place now a
lot of people lost their jobs over this
so you know it's not like it's it's so
clear that the government got it right
uh and then they also block debate I
mean I think if you want to build trust
you have to build institutions that are
willing to engage in debate and and be
open-minded instead of what we had
during the pandemic and it's funny Dr
Burke who mentions that we're speaking
about culturals that start the show and
values based buying because a lot of
this does strike to that argument about
whether people are thinking in an
ideological way or believing science and
whether both can happen at the same time
it's all about freedom of speech it's
all about being able to choose your side
isn't it but when it comes to a pandemic
and a public health emergency do
scientists know best is there a
rationale for them overstepping and
dictating how people should live
well I think we've learned from prior
pandemics that you have to put all the
information out there in a digestible
way and when you cut Corners when you
cut Corners pretending that if you're
infected you are protected from future
infections you're not protected from
covet if you've been naturally infected
or multiply vaccinated you can get
infected and I just I just feel like
we've divided this into an absolute when
this is not an absolute virus we don't
even know to this day whether long coved
what it really is how many people get it
and what are the long-term consequences
of multiple covet infections it is not
flu it's a unique virus it's it is still
being discovered what it does and I I
agree with Dr J about really continuing
to put the information out there in an
honest and transparent way so that
people can make decisions by both
ignoring the fact that covet is still
with us as well as pretending that our
vaccines can reduce herd immunity and
protect against infection leads people
absolutely confused and you see this
even now today in the United States
where they have politicized rural health
and implying that people in rural areas
are dying at a higher rate because of
their vaccine status it is because they
don't have access to any tools because
Primary Care isn't there anymore and
they've been dying at a higher rate from
cancer diabetes hypertension all of
these other diseases for 15 years and
we're acting like it was because of how
they voted versus their access to health
care so I'm hoping that everybody steps
back and looks at what the true issues
are and for the UK please keep your data
up we've decided that coven doesn't
exist and we've taken our data down so I
use your data to understand what's
happening and what we're going to see in
the United States in order to protect my
mother are you going to get a lot more
data price a lot of people covered in
the UK at the moment Dr J before we wrap
up I just want to ask you where
information is one thing but legislation
of course is another at least 30 states
with Republican legislation have passed
laws since 2020 limiting Public Health
authorities that was reported in the
Washington Post so basically legislating
into the next pandemic that Health
authorities can't say You must wear a
mask or these schools can't be locked
down depends on a state-by-state basis
do you think that's wise
yes I do I think that the public health
authorities abuse the TR their trust the
public had in them during the pandemic
violated basic civil liberties including
freedom of speech freedom of Association
freedom to worship uh and huge huge
violations of basic rights uh people
people like need to live they need to
you know go see their their elderly
parents they need to they and
authoritarian orders that violate that
that uh should not be given in the hands
of Public Health who can't be who have
shown themselves to be untrustworthy if
Public Health wants to control Behavior
they should do it in honest Ways by
giving good solid formation being open
to correction from the outside and then
if they're giving honest advice people
will listen to it it's trust that is the
key not mandates and authority of the
sort that public health irrigated as
well itself during the pandemic trust
certainly is key we've been hearing from
some top scientific voices evening Dr J
Dr Deborah thank you very much for your
time
thank you uncensored next tonight the
racism Rao that has rocked the country
music world will debate the Rights and
Wrongs of trying that in a small town
all become clear next
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
country music it's faced controversy
over the last few weeks all of this
centering around a song by Jason Aldean
called try that in a small town critics
saying the lyrics and the images in the
video are racist dog whistles take a
look at a listen
[Music]
see how far you make it down the road
in case you missed it in the accent
there he said cuts out a cop spit in his
face stomp on the flag and light it up
yeah you think you're tough we'll try
that in a small town sounds a bit
different coming out a British mouth
doesn't it uh what do you think of it
all the video meanwhile is caused up bro
it's set on the steps of Maury County
Courthouse in Columbia Tennessee the
site of a 1927 lynching of a black man
not that the controversy has been bad
for the record's chart position saying
all this at the weekend try that in a
small town rocketed to the top of the
Billboard Hot 100 charts the first
country song to achieve that feat in
over a decade we thought it was worth
debating the Rights and Wrongs of this
song I'm joined from Nashville the home
of country music of course by outkick
host Tommy Lauren Tommy thanks so much
for making time here in the studio
comedian and radio presenter James Barr
and talktv contributor Paula Roan Adrian
and I feel like I should make some
personal disclosures before starting
this debate because I live in a small
town or a village we call them here in
the UK I absolutely love country music
and I can declare some ignorance when it
comes to watch this video I watched it
on my way and today and I thought well I
don't see much race kind of presented
here the rioting footage they've used is
quite carefully selected
um some saying it's coming from the 2020
covered riots not quite confirmed but
then I learned about the building
they're standing in front of just remind
you it is a County Courthouse in
Tennessee with an 18 year old black man
named Henry Choate was lynched in 1927
and they're quite visibly standing
outside it throughout so I think
important to add that context let's head
to Tommy Lauren standing by for us in
Nashville Tommy I mean I know you're
going to make a defense for this because
you've been very outspoken about it why
isn't it racist
well first of all it's not racist
because we're using actual footage of
the summer 2020 Riot season you know
when covet took a Hiatus for several
weeks in the United States so I don't
know how something could possibly be
racist when you're actually showing
depictions of real events that actually
happened has nothing to do with race and
everything to do with behavior and
furthermore there's been a lot to do
about this Courthouse but it's also
important to note that this courthouse
is a popular filming location not just
for this music video but for Hallmark
movies other music videos and other
Christmas specials so it's not as if
this was picked out of the Oblivion like
this is the first time this has ever
been used yes it has a dark history but
since then there's been several projects
done there that have nothing to do with
race nothing to do with politics and for
a Hallmark Christmas special for
goodness sake so people trying to make
this about race is just because they
want to ignore the message try that in a
small town and what that means has
nothing to do with race and everything
to do with basic human decency you can't
get away with this kind of thing in
small towns because in small towns
people look out for one another they
don't put up with people riding looting
burning the city down and that is the
intention of this song and to me that's
where this song lands I mean it has been
called out for encouraging violence pull
a gun on the owner of a liquor store you
think it's cool we're active fool if you
like they talk about getting their own
runs got a gun that my granddad gave me
so it's meeting violence and violence
let's bring in our voices from the
studio Paula do you feel it's racist so
look I we can't deny that there is a
very micro aggressive underbelly here in
terms of where this video was shot we
can't deny that the images that have
been portrayed are about violence and
about people protesting and we know that
people were protesting black lives
matter it was all tied up in relation to
race but can I just say something uh to
Tommy I think Tommy knows this is about
race because Tommy understands what the
Deep South is about Tommy understands
the history of the Deep South Tommy
understands what happened to the
gentleman who was lynched Tommy
understands about the riots that
happened in the 1940s in relation to
this particular building and the black
men who were killed Tommy understands
all of that
um and that you know we are very clear
about the message that's been sent this
isn't a person who is saying uh we are a
small town and we uphold the law and we
should report bad things to the police
this is a person who is saying I'm a
member of a gang and if you come into my
town I'm going to deal with you it's an
eye for an eye Justice and we are past
that surely
a response to that are you aware of that
are you just choosing to willfully
ignore it
Ah that's laughable and clearly from
somebody who doesn't understand country
music or really the United States of
America and our culture you know I'm not
fine I have my blue jeans I have my blue
jeans and I'm proud to wear them I love
tonight I love country music and I love
that you love country music but I will
tell you this I am from a small town in
South Dakota not the Deep South and this
song speaks to me because in my small
town in South Dakota in the Midwest of
the United States it has nothing to do
with coming to my town and I'm going to
enact violence upon you it's saying if
you're going to come here be decent if
you start burning things down and
looting you will probably be dealt with
in the way that you should be dealt with
and that is a return
I'm from a small town as well and you
know my neighbor Gladys might take the
post in for me if I'm out but she's not
going to pull a gun on someone that has
a different opinion Tommy Tommy I think
I also want to say it's funny that you
could a difference of 2020 right season
that's a laughable
if you want to look at footage of a riot
maybe you should look at the capital
riots that would be a more interesting
opportunity we don't live in the United
States you do not live in the United
States for a solid two months
issues more than you and Jason Aldean
considering I don't live in the U.S this
is a song lyrically with very
threatening language and a video that
has been filmed outside of a courthouse
with a very deeply racist history why
didn't you just Google it and why didn't
you choose that footage it is racist
Tommy and you know that it is and we're
not talking about God bless USA are we
we're not talking about that great
patriotic song which I appreciate that
not everybody loves but you know that is
a song that a lot of people will sign up
to and understand the words and
understand what it was hoping to achieve
this song is clearly about getting sales
it's clearly about making people angry
it's clearly about getting people to
fight one another look Tommy listen
you've all you've already said you know
we're not Americans we're waiting on
American issue here is it just that
Brits don't get country music
yeah that's partly it but I'll also say
this I find it rather disturbing that
those of you have such an issue with
this song and music video but don't seem
to have much of an issue with American
cities being burned to the ground
businesses owned by black people white
people brown people being looted for
every penny that they have the fact that
you are angry at a music video for
showcasing that behavior and not that
behavior to me is very telling and very
appalling I'd like to let's talk to you
I'm not angry about this one it's got
quite a nice melody Tommy like it's it's
a fine song but lyrically you can't
argue with the fact that it is
threatening or so the last time I
visited New York it hadn't burned down
it was perfectly fine I think most
Americans are very loving empathetic
people I think it's really sad that you
can't see the truth behind this song
it's stoking a culture War to hit number
one and it did it so I want to ask in
the studio as well whether country
music's just gonna country music James
you know well there have been some but
very few it must be said gay country
singers there have been very few black
country singers the top 100 whatever uh
you know country music artists 139 that
there are I think three of them are
black
um but then black music has its own
space as well is there an argument for
separate spaces here uh it's listen that
doesn't give you the excuse to incite
violence and actually there are a lot of
different musicians from all sorts of
different genres that do that too and
that's also wrong and a lot of the
country and western singers they do
collaborate with black artists black
artists from the hip-hop world black
artists who from the pop world so this
isn't about country western music this
is about this song and the message that
this song is put is giving out to people
thank you both in the studio uh Tommy
before we go give our sense our
International audience a sense of what
the receptions of songs been like and I
understand you know the singer Jason
Aldean personally how's he been dealing
with it all
listen he's not backing down go woke go
broke and this song is getting the
reverse Bud Light treatment and for good
reason because Americans are so sick and
tired of being told that we should deal
with rioting and burning and looting
we'd like to get back to good old
American values and that works for all
Races we all love each other we defend
each other that's what try that in a
small town means nothing into his
children
how many more innocent children who are
walking down the street or who knock on
the wrong door who knock on the door by
mistake and get shot at how many more
children do we need to see lose their
lives to guns that's what this song is
telling it's saying pick up your gun and
come to my town and I will deal with you
I won't go to the police all of you it's
been fascinating we appreciate it thank
you uncensored next tonight it's been a
day of commemoration in Ireland by the
great Sinead O'Connor was laid to rest
with talking to Dave Fanning about the
Legacy she leaves behind coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk the government
threatens to withdraw support from
migrants who refused aboard the Bibby
Stockholm barge Labor's left Road faced
after one of its candidates was revealed
as an Eco activist and the 1975 faced
legal action after the band's on stage
kiss at a Malaysian music festival
that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now Sinead
O'Connor was laid to rest today in her
home county of Wicklow thousands of
locals turned out to pay their respects
including former survivors of the
infamous maglin laundries the president
of Ireland and pop Legends Bob Geldof
and Bono from YouTube are joining me to
discuss sinead's Legacy is Irish DJ and
friend of the singer Dave Fanning thank
you for making time on this day Dave and
then just talk to us a little bit about
the Legacy that Sinead leaves behind and
what new new offer
well the Legacy would probably be I mean
like if you look back like 33 years is a
long time so that was the time she made
a really big impact when she tore up the
picture of the Pope on TV and a lot of
people thought you know what's this
about and a lot of people there today
probably were even behind the idea that
you know who is this kind of oppity
petulant woman you know who was sort of
basically put out in front for a
metaphorical sort of stoning she was the
target of a staggering amount of video
including public protests Etc and this
worldwide sort of misogynistic temper
tantrum she really took it on the chin
and she knew exactly what she was doing
and she was telling the truth completely
and a lot of people just didn't really
want to know 10 years later we found out
that she was telling the truth and 10
and 10 more years in other words 30
years now since we find out just how bad
the situation actually really was a nest
of devils she called it right off the
top of the Vatican and she was 100
correct but other things too many other
social issues she spoke about so many
things and she was a spiritual Seeker in
the deepest sense as well and her
religion like today for the last day too
the Imam said some fantastic things
about it too which basically you know
she just it was just too much of a world
that she had to live in because she was
not you know she was never she had a lot
of sort of issues in terms of her mental
health turns through the years yeah I
mean so many different strands that we
can go into there too much of the world
and yes to remind obviously she did
convert to Islam a few years ago so she
had a Muslim uh burial today
um also just the facts of what's going
on just in case anyone watching uh isn't
aware no cause of death has yet been
revealed
um and she was of course a mother of
four she survived by three of her
children
um one of the Magdalene survivors
actually says that Sinead changed
Ireland forever what do you think uh was
meant by that because as you said that
she was just never shy to stray away
from these really complex topics and
speak out on them
changed Ireland absolutely she changed
Ireland I mean even in terms of the
hashtag me too I mean like you know she
was many years before all of that kind
of thing she was like there was a huge
breakthrough for feminism every few
years with the type of things she was
saying some people were there today I
saw them being interviewed talking about
the fact that you know she gave me the
kind of opportunity or she gave me the
right to be who I actually am as opposed
to who Society might have wanted one to
be because this was a very patriarchal
society at the time and she was really
like out there in terms of this is what
I want to say this is what I want people
to believe and in so many ways there's
been a lot of documentaries recently
that absorbed to correct kind of the
record of several women who are once
punching bags you know I mean even we're
all guilty maybe of looking at you know
Red Top newspapers from 13 or 14 years
ago and whatever Britney Spears oh look
she's cut her hair off and all the rest
but Britney Spears and Lorena Bobbitt
and Pamela Anderson and Monica Lewinsky
and Sinead was probably about the first
to be canceled of all the ones I'm
mentioning and then people seen today
for people to see in the last two weeks
I should say just how prescient she was
and just how much she had a finger on
the pulse absolutely now those mental
health concerns that you raised again
very very public
um fortunate she was outspoken about
them how do you think she changed the
way that mental health was perceived
especially amongst celebrities and
singers as you said there who are very
much in the glare the public eye all the
time
I don't think that Sinead herself was
very much kind of on some kind of a
crusade on that level because she had a
lot of problems of her own there's a lot
of trauma a lot of controversies and big
mental health struggles which of course
she played out of the public house she
always wanted to be listened to she
always wants to be heard she certainly
wasn't shy about it all but um just you
know obviously in terms of so much that
we've seen with the man that binds and
so many others down through the last few
years it is out there in the open and I
would say also that even in terms of
singers from PJ Harvey to Alanis
Morissette to a few others Sinead opened
the door for all of that kind of thing
to be angry and upfront and you know not
necessarily to be the what was it that
she said about you know you don't have
to sort of be there just for men's sort
of approval or whatever you have to be
who you want to be and
at Morrissey has come out uh in the days
after we found out about her death to
say look where were you all in essence I
can't remember his exact wording but
where were you all when she most needed
it here you are with the platitudes now
you're crying for her now but where were
you then do you think that's fair
I do actually in so many ways yeah I do
think it took a long time for people to
actually embrace Sinead if you like many
people did in the 90s but I mean it has
taken the last two weeks it's changed an
awful lot of things it's terrible to
think that her death had to do all of
that but she was exposing the sexism and
the Casual cruelty that was rampant in
the media not just stuff that was going
on in the Catholic church and I do think
that you know what she has done I can
get exactly what I think it was somebody
else was giving out about that today as
well I can't remember oh Lily Allen she
was also saying the same thing and they
have a point because at the time you've
got to remember that there are people
even there today at the funeral who
probably feel slightly guilty that back
in the early 90s they were kind of going
who is basically this Looney what's her
problem and they were now you know we've
covered some very heavy topics from her
lifetime it seemed to be uh scattered
with them but of course she was also
just as you a personal friend to you I'm
sure you shed light moments as well have
you got any personal Recollections that
you can share of your favorite times
with Sinead but one of the things a
couple of years ago we were going to
make this documentary about her and she
said most people think I'm you know
complete and absolute loony and I said
really I wonder why and we just fell
around laughed I mean like obviously she
knows she wasn't stupid you know like
she was very Fearless she was very
fragile often at the same moment and
often in the same Psalm she was very
self-deprecating she was uncompromising
she was a sharp Observer of so many
different things but also she was
incredibly kind and like there was
nothing in her life she never wanted the
fame that she got from that second album
from nothing compares to you and she
immediately threw it all away in fact
her next album was a selection of jazz
Classics and then after that knowing
that her albums weren't going to top
charts so weren't going to get in the
way of all the pop music that was going
on by the way nothing to do with like
say you know the Madonna who was just as
famous at the time if they want to go
off and want to be pop stars that's fine
and she wasn't even against that it just
that was not for her and the album she
released were kind of explorations of
certain genres of music that she wanted
to go to so for instance until 2002 the
Channel's newer album was just old Irish
traditional singing album three years
later popped off to um Jamaica and slide
on Byron Robbie Shakespeare the two
famous producers produced a reggae album
and that's what she wanted to do she has
a bunch of songs ready to go which she
played me recently which uh David Holmes
the um Belfast musician DJ producer Etc
has made and um I presume that's the
last that she has but I mean her last
two albums actually from 2012 to 2014
some of the best pop songs she's ever
released but by that stage people
weren't necessarily buying Sinead albums
that didn't really worry Sinead I can
tell you that's not what she was in it
for working right up until the end just
quickly Dave before we let you go and
thank you for sharing all your
Recollections uh one track that people
should listen to when they're thinking
of Sinead well I go for a try myself or
but wouldn't I go for one of the happy
ones on on the last time like fourth and
Vine I think that's a great song but you
know Troy is the one from the from the
early album fourth and Vine there you go
that's the recommendation recommendation
from Dave Fanning thank you for sharing
your Recollections or Sinead uh Connor's
day when she was laid to rest that is it
from me whatever you're doing make sure
it is uncensored I'll be back here in
the chair tomorrow night good night
foreign
[Music]
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appears to
be an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty KTM that would make her a better
princess of wealth because you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
can we did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic